in your hand in your hand oh Lord Oh
[Music]
Lord
en there you go there you go there
you I think it's safe to say that in one
film done something that I don't know
has ever been done before which is you
got like the greatest performance by
hands I've ever seen so how do you
direct
hands you know for me it's not about
calling attention to the hands it's
about I want a full body experience you
know and so it's getting at the
emotionality and trusting I trust the
ways the body communicates you know and
I of course trust the actors to be in
their body and I try not to call
attention to the fact that I'm on the
hands and Trust how their body naturally
you know wants to hold something or let
something go or Express itself at what
point in the process I'm curious did you
arrive was it conversations with Joo
your DP who I think did beautiful work
on this film that you knew you were
going to focus close up on certain body
parts that you found very expressive in
that way I love eyes but hands are right
up there for me so I
knew that going in that there would be a
lot of hands a lot of details I knew
that but and so it was a mix but it was
a discovery on set just how much space
the hands wanted to take up you know and
how that's another layer these slant
Rhymes in the film of speaking to these
characters and the relationships and the
changes that they go through what's that
process of writing like when so much of
the storytelling in the eventual film I
imagine didn't necessarily live on the
page initially how are you like
preparing to tell a story with all these
other tools yeah you know Mississippi is
in the log line but I never say in the
film and this is Mississippi you know
what I mean I really wanted to get at
Place through a feeling rather than
concretely stating it being very
intentional with you know details of the
time with costume design I looked a lot
at my grandma's photo albums being very
intentional with the details to again
speak to the time period and place
without needing to announce it what were
those conversations like with your key
collaborators as your first sort of
bringing them into this thing that is so
personal to you it's a fiction film but
it's very close you know it's like I
there's a lot of emotional truths and
details in it and with the conversations
it was seeing you know do we have a
similar sensibility I would say I think
the biggest part was just are we
speaking the same like you know what I
mean as far as what this film is going
to be and making sure you're making the
same film right and once that's
established it's the trust of ooh I'm
curious what you're going to come back
with I was also curious about clay dirt
and eating it and your own Fam Family
connection to that and why have the many
Traditions I imagine that were passed
down that felt like one that you really
wanted to in a way build this film
around the title of the film comes from
a conversation I have with my grandma
around the practice of eating clay DT
and I actually wrote a poem first with
that title that has nothing to do with
the film years before I even knew I
would come to this film um and believe
it or not the film didn't even with that
title didn't always have the clay dirt
eating in it oh wow right yeah um it was
something I came to like the it felt
like the film wanted that title but I
from the beginning like I had the title
before I had written a page I knew that
was a title um but adding the thread
came later in the process and once I
added that there I was like o this ties
everything
together for me it's the closeness to
the Earth the rain is often after rain
when the earth smells so rich that those
who practice eating clay dirt eat it and
I didn't grow up eating clay dirt my
mother did though and my my grandma did
her you know it was passed down and so
it felt like um I have eaten it now you
know it's a snack and it tastes good to
me um but it's different because I got
it online it's different my my aunt
makes fun of me she's like you don't
um but it felt in a film that deals so
much with tradition and what's passed
down from generation to generation it
felt and again these characters are so
close to Nature it felt like a detail
that speaks to it all yeah which that's
what really uh inspired me to add it
right right one of the moments that
feels just really memorable to me in
this is the hug there's such a beautiful
Arc in that that hug I wonder about just
if you can talk about the process of
like writing that and developing it and
whether things that came out on the day
that weren't what you expected because
it feels like such a big moment in the
film and it unfolds it keeps kind of
unfolding in ways that are just really
draw you in so we shot that that was one
of that was the second to last day of
shooting intentionally so I wanted it to
be scheduled later so they had you know
a history to pull from as people but it
was a discovery and being present to see
it's not going to these people have a
rich history haven't seen each other for
a long time they're not going to hug for
15 seconds they're not going to hug for
a minute you know what I mean and so it
was telling Reggie in some moments you
know just a little longer just a little
longer she smells the same you know and
allowing room for that and I really I
like to create a bubble
when I'm working with the actors around
as much as possible you know and just
like giving them the space to just go
deeper and deeper with each take and
they really went there you know and it
was really yeah that's one of my
favorite days on that just one thing
about that the bubble what what what is
the bubble is it just you and Jo M fre
your DP and them and and like you just
said you were kind of whispering to them
directing them in that way what's that
yeah what's that like yeah I mean just
in general I don't like a lot of people
around when I'm directing or around the
actors we're trying to often go to
vulnerable places and I don't like and
also for me I just don't like a lot of
noise or distractions in that way and so
for that scene it was you know trying to
have people you know at video Village as
much as possible even though some folks
uh go by the AC monitor you know and but
it's like as much as possible and
luckily with the grocery store there was
like a Place Ral tode that the actors
wouldn't be able to see anything so it
really did feel like uper just me the
actors and jumo you know um to again
allow more space to go to these deep
emotional places the Cena is asking
for
and um so yeah and then it's me try me
going to them pulling them to the side
and having a conversation with them or
and not not always a conversation
maybe it's just me saying one thing you
know what I mean one thing that unlocks
something M but doing it to the side you
talked about this a little bit earlier
but um you know on a film with a limited
budget sometimes one of the first things
to go are is that great minutia and all
the
detail what was that process like on set
when you know that's so critical to this
film The you know butterfly wing
clapping together the bird song like and
you know that's going to be really
important part of your
storytelling how did you fight to
maintain those things in this film we
talked a lot about how you
know like there not b-roll you know like
we need like this we need these shots
you know these textural shots these
World shots are right up there with the
the other shots and luckily I'm not
someone who does a lot of takes cuz it's
all about time you know and I'm not
someone who does a lot takes so we're
able to and having Maria there who
understood how I like to work was
helpful in that regard um but it was it
was very important from jump I think to
make it clear
that the film needs these things these
aren't um just if we can get it it's no
we need we're making time building that
into the schedule making sure that that
scene is essential right right right um
is there something for you uh that feels
especially important you want people to
take away from this film it feels
critical I think I've heard you say you
want it to wash over people why why that
specifically I feel this
film is an experience in a lot of ways
and which is and that's what I'm aiming
for
for um it to wash over folks and and and
hopefully there's enough there's room
for even this is a very specific film
intentionally so but with this the
specifics for folks to be able to bring
their full selves to it you know and a
question I asked in the making of it was
if our lies were to flood what are those
moments that would rise to the surface
and how would they swim between each
other how would they speak to each other
you know and that that washing the film
washing over the audience washing over a
person feels like you know a fluid
experience of a life you know and which
speaks to what I'm I'm trying to get at
and so that's why I I really I
really yeah hope folks allow it to to be
an
experience the last thing I want to ask
you um for a movie that deals with
family so beautifully in multiple
Generations how has your family felt
about this film this must be really
special for them to see it come out and
just be received the way it has been so
what's that been like for them yeah you
know it's been beautiful they they love
the film but what else are they going to
tell
me um and they they came to the New York
Film Festival Premiere and my mom had
like a photograph from the Sundance
stepp and repeat on her shirt and so it
was really cute you know they they are
proud and and and it was I I'm really my
dad actually he
recommended the if I were your woman the
Glatt n the PIP song for the Dan and so
you know it's it's uh I know they see
them and it's my dad's tackle and the
fishing scene so I know they see yeah
and there's like family photo albums on
some of family photographs from albums
in some of the scenes so I know they
see within again it's a fiction film but
inide the details they see themselves
which um I'm grateful for and I know
that adds to like their experience of it
yeah yeah well thank you so much for
being here thank you for making such a
beautiful Brave film and thank you guys
for coming to see it thank you Joe and
thank you
all